From guest appearances as street magicians to
recurring roles as psychotic plastic surgeons,
Castle has hosted a lot of
famous faces in its cast.
Annie Wersching played the role of Dr. Kelly
Nieman in Seasons 6 and 7 on Castle. Neiman
was a villainess and plastic surgeon who secretly
worked alongside Michael Mosley's serial killer,
Jerry Tyson. Wersching's performance
stood out as one of the strongest
one-off villains in the series for
her calculating, demented doctor.
"Good. You're awake. We can get started."
Wersching initially gained fame for her role as
Renee Walker in Seasons 7 and 8 of the series
24 — an extremely tough, willful, and complex
character frequently butting heads with Jack
Bauer. Other significant roles in her filmography
include Amelia Joffe in General Hospital,
Julia Brasher in Bosch, Emma Whitmore in
Timeless, and the Borg Queen in Star Trek:
Picard. She also gained critical acclaim for her
motion-capture performance as Tess in the 2013
video game, The Last of Us. Wersching tragically
passed away from cancer on January 29, 2023.
You may not have realized Chadwick Boseman was
even in Castle, but he appears in Episode 12 of
Season 3 as a magician named Chuck Russell.
Although he's only there as the red herring
suspect for the murder of a fellow magician,
Boseman stands out in his rather silly role.
Boseman is adored worldwide for his starring
role as T'Challa the Black Panther in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. He made his first appearance
as the character in 2016's Captain America:
Civil War but was given his own film in 2018.
He continued the role throughout Avengers:
Infinity War and Endgame until
his tragic passing in 2020 from
colon cancer. He was praised for his acting
talent, charitable work, and philanthropy,
with many celebrating his legacy in
popular culture, including a statement
by Black Panther director Ryan Coogler.
According to Den of Geek, Coogler claimed,
"[Boseman] was such an integral part of that
character for us, both as the character and
as a person, that we could not conceive of
a version with having someone else on set."
Although Len Lesser plays a very small role
in Castle, the famous character actor is
still remembered for his part in the second
episode of Season 1. Lesser makes his minor
appearance count as the funny distraction
from an ongoing murder investigation.
"He's not a cop. I'm a cop."
"And you're looking for someone to have sex with?"
Lesser may be familiar to audiences from
his standout role as Uncle Leo in the hit
NBC sitcom Seinfeld. His character made his first
appearance in the 2nd season of the show as Jerry
Seinfeld's eccentric uncle who frequently gives
his nephew trouble about a variety of overblown
inconveniences. Uncle Leo was so beloved,
he's ranked at #6 on Rolling Stone's "100
Best Seinfeld Characters" list. Sadly, Len Lesser
passed away in 2011 at the age of 88. According
to HuffPost, Jerry Seinfeld made an official
statement following Lesser's death, stating,
"Len was one of our favorites. We always loved
having him on the show. I'll never forget when
Uncle Leo was in prison and tattooed 'Jerry
Hello' on his knuckles. He was a very sweet guy."
Chad Everett was a prolific actor who appeared in
almost 100 movies and television shows over his
50-year career. His last credited on-screen
role was in Season 4, Episode 14 of Castle,
where he plays Jerry Maddox, a former private
investigator going under the name Joe Flynn.
While this role can be considered a footnote
in his career, the appearance came just before
his death from lung cancer in July of
2012. Everett was mainly known for his
portrayal of Dr. Joe Gannon in the CBS
series Medical Center from 1969 to 1976,
with his other notable parts being in Airplane
II: The Sequel, The Nanny, and Mulholland Drive.
Unlike any of the other Castle actors on this
list, Wes Craven was the only one to make a cameo
appearance as himself during Season 5. The episode
revolved around Castle and Beckett investigating
the death of a woman who was convinced she was
cursed from watching a haunted video tape. This
episode's obvious homage to horror flicks like
The Ring explains why horror icon Craven shows up.
"Is Stephen King beating you
at Texas Hold 'Em again?"
"Yeah, right."
Craven is best known for the cult classics The
Last House on the Left and The Hills Have Eyes,
as well as the massive horror franchises
A Nightmare on Elm Street and Scream.
Craven passed away from a brain
tumor in 2015 at the age of 76,
and is remembered as a pioneer of horror
moviemaking. During one interview with fellow
horror director Mick Garris, Craven
summed up his filmmaking philosophy,
"You realize you're doing something
that means something to people,
so — Shut up and get back to work."
Fans of Castle will no doubt remember Nathaniel
Marston's performance as Grant Vyro in the Season
3 episode titled "The Last Call." Vyro was a
union dock worker operating under the false
identity of a dead man, but — ultimately — had a
verifiable alibi to clear him of any wrongdoing.
Marston was a successful actor who was mainly
known for his roles on the ABC soap opera One
Life to Live. Marston played the character Al
Holden from 2001 to 2003, and became Dr. Michael
McBain from 2004 to 2007, after Holden dies and
his spirit transitions into McBain. Marston had
other minor roles in Law & Order: Special Victims
Unit, White Collar, and Blue Bloods. Marston died
from surgery complications in 2015, after
he was severely injured in a car accident.
Robin Sachs appeared as the
Announcer in Season 4, Episode 13,
in which Castle investigates
the death of a dog trainer.
"Only one question remains. Who
will be this year's Best in Show?"
Sachs became well known for his performances
in film, television, and theater over his
decades-long career. He is probably best
known for his part as Ethan Rayne in Buffy
the Vampire Slayer, a recurring antagonist
against Buffy and her crew. Sachs was also
known for many minor roles, including The Lost
World: Jurassic Park, Galaxy Quest, and Babylon
5. Sachs passed away from a fatal heart attack in
2013, just four days short of his 62nd birthday.
Although only supplying a small cameo as
one of Castle's regular poker buddies,
the story of Stephen J. Cannell goes much
deeper than that. Cannell was a writer,
producer, and novelist who had a hand
in many successful television series,
which includes The A-Team,
Renegade, and 21 Jump Street.
Cannell openly struggled with dyslexia
throughout his early life and career,
some of which was chronicled in
the 2012 documentary Dislecksia:
The Movie. He was an important factor
in the creation of Castle and — as a
result — he was given a special tribute at
the end of a Season 3 episode which read,
"Stephen J. Cannell. Colleague.
Mentor. Friend. We'll miss you, pal."
Cannell passed away in September of 2010 due to
complications from melanoma at the age of 69.
When it comes to hard-working
character actors in Hollywood,
few were as impressive as Jon Polito. While
his only minor role in Castle was as a
witness convinced that the world is still in the
1970s, he nonetheless stood out as a highlight.
"That's a nice dress. Can I talk you out of it?"
Polito was a unique character actor who started
in TV and movies in the 1980s with roles in The
Gangster Chronicles, Highlander, and the Coen
brothers' Miller's Crossing — arguably stealing
the show as the weaselly Johnny Caspar. Polito's
profile grew as he snagged bigger roles in the
Coen brothers' films Barton Fink and The Big
Lebowski, as well as appearing as Bigelow in
The Rocketeer, and Gideon the pawn shop owner in
The Crow. He passed away in 2016 at the age of 65.